resistant or his
freedom
our message is we address all
the peoples of the world I will be paid that
what we are undergoing this
is not normal they have to
wake up
I am coming  here for my grandchildren
I'm not anti-
valorization that's out of the question
every round is free to make
mattel songs
and well what we want is for the
government to stop this happening a
land that all that  either who has
no more measure we want freedom that's
all
and I say we are against this vaccine there
it's not a vaccine it's a
mixture that kills that's all it would end
like we thank you  man series touches stop
at the ago in d'offenbach the isf he is
like a son and
brother said
I come
from france in isère
and the message is addressed to the government
to the deputies so that they stop this
humbug of pass which is used to  nothing,
give us back our freedoms, give us back
our children's smiles
[Music]